you're a lawyer attacking other lawyers
how can I am but I mean typically when
something's good for lawyers it's
probably not good for everybody else hi
i'm paul dietrich with reason TV today
we're talking with cal rouse t allah
rusty ala is a law professor at UCLA
he's also the co-author of the book the
knockoff economy how imitation sparks
innovation now when I think of copycats
I think of them as riding on the
coattails of other creative people why
is that wrong
well it's wrong because that's not
always true and in fact it's often not
true I guess the way I would put it is
that a lot of innovation grows out of
imitation so it's not so much riding on
the coattails as it is standing on the
shoulders and what's the difference
between counterfeit and copying it
depends on the context but I'd say in
the fashion context counterfeits usually
refer to the label being copied so R
example you can go to a place like
Santee alley here in Los Angeles and you
can find fake gucci sunglasses those are
counterfeits on the other hand you could
walk into the forever 21 store nearby
and find a knocked off dress meaning a
copy of a design of a dress by gucci
that's a copy and that's legal the
people that make pants and dresses what
do they have to teach patent lawyers I
mean I think the biggest lesson to draw
out of the fashion industry is that
intellectual property rights are not a
necessary feature for innovation or for
creative work certain aspects of
intellectual property are very important
so the trademark is really significant
and they're very vigilant about
trademark but the designs as we talked
about a moment ago they're copy freely
and legally in this country and we have
a thriving garment industry even if
you're being copied then you know you're
in style absolutely I mean if you if you
talk to designers they're all over the
map on this issue but we quote several
different designers in the book to say
either something like I'm very glad that
I'm copied because if I'm not copied you
know I'm clearly not in the game or you
know copying is just part of the air we
breathe this is how this industry works
for those that aren't fans of fashion
what can we learn from football and
innovation well football is really
interesting in this regard because like
fashion football plays and formations
are unprotected by copyright law so you
might think of player formation as kind
of a choreographic work which is
protected but no
successfully been able to make that
claim so as a practical matter every
time a college coach or a pro coach
comes up with a new formation that is
going to be copied if it's successful by
their opposition and opposing teams do
that all the time so again this begs the
question why do they keep creating if
they know they're going to be copied
because that's that this runs counter to
everything we think about intellectual
property and the answer is it's
incredibly competitive in football and
competition itself drives a lot of
innovation 1 & 2 first mover advantage
the fact that you are the first to use
something will often give you enough of
an edge to justify that innovation
because it takes the other team a
certain amount of time not just to learn
that new player formation but also to
train in it and to adapt it so that
advantage can be significant and that's
true of a lot of industries I remember
in the 90s when I was a kid I was
downloading so much stuff off of Napster
there's this new place to find music and
it was music for free and then the music
industry got caught up in arms over
overtime trying to sue Napster trying to
sue everybody for copyright infringement
how was the music industry innovated
itself well I would say they haven't
innovated enormous lis but there's been
some big changes in a few areas probably
the most interesting for this purpose is
actually iTunes so if you look at iTunes
iTunes has had over 10 billion downloads
add roughly $1 a pop so that's a pretty
good business and Apple has become a
huge player in the music industry
whereas it wasn't before and I think one
important lesson there is people are
still illegally downloading for sure but
a lot of people are going to iTunes and
the reason is iTunes makes it super easy
to find what you want and relatively
cheap to buy it so I think the lesson is
if you take advantage of the internet
rather than viewing it as something
that's gonna kill you something that you
hate which is the reaction of the music
industry initially didn't Napster
consumers will follow and unfortunately
for a lot of the record labels it's a
lesson they learned a little too late
would you say that the copiers were on
the cutting edge of the industry I would
say that the part of the problem in our
discussions about music and this is a
point we emphasize in the knockoff
economy is that we tend to think of the
music industry and music as kind of the
same thing and in fact they're very
difference so from a consumer point of
view we're in a golden age for music
there's
the music out there whatever a record
store or place used to go in the I'm
older than you are let's say in the 80s
pre-internet couldn't cover a hundredth
of that of the material that you can
find on let's say just Amazon today let
alone iTunes or something else from a
musician's point of view in some ways
it's a much easier world the same
technologies that have made illegal
downloading possible make it possible to
sit in your bedroom with your computer
and maybe a couple of software programs
create an entire album and distribute it
online to the world without going into a
studio without signing a contract with a
record label
without having to deal with any of those
intermediaries the point that I want to
make about music and it goes across the
board is that copying has destructive
effects and the music industry the music
labels exemplify that but it also has
productive effects and the freedom to
copy the ability to copy has had both
good and bad elements and I think music
is a wonderful exemplar of that what
kind of innovation comes from the food
we do at restaurants we live in an
incredibly creative time for food I
would say probably the greatest time in
history there's more amazing ideas I'm
about to go over to Roy Choi's
restaurant chaego Roy Choi is the
inventor of the Korean taco known as
Kogi is the instructor though is he the
inventor of tacos and and Korean there
is some dispute there is some but I'll
say that he is um for the purposes of
this discussion he's certainly the
leading popularizer of it and probably
the inventor of the particular Kogi taco
that we know today very popular in Los
Angeles and it's now spread all over the
country so cuisine is a creative field
and there's a lot of knocking off and
it's perfectly legal like the fashion
industry you can copy a recipe
completely legally you can go and say
hey I want to create my own taco truck
and I'm gonna call it bogie and it's
gonna look just like that I'm gonna
serve the same things you can do that as
long as you're not confusing consumers
who think it's Kogi perfectly legal
nonetheless is a lot of creativity who
knows tomorrow or right now what new
form of taco is being created so I think
the biggest lesson is that intellectual
property law is not as important as we
might think to innovation so in the
patent
texts patents can be very important in
certain areas especially when you have
big upfront costs and we are forthright
about that in the book we recognize that
not every industry is the same but still
there is innovation even in areas where
patents normally apply and you might
question whether we need all the patents
that we have or whether patents should
be as broad so for example in the Apple
Samsung case that just happened apple
claims a patent in the rectangular
design of the iPad and the iPhone they
own a rectangle you mean they try to say
that they own the rectangle the jury
upheld that for the phone it sort of
split the difference on the iPad it
didn't say that Samsung infringed but it
also didn't say the patent was invalid
it's a bigger rectangle it's bigger
rectangle now what's interesting about
that is of course you're holding a piece
of paper I've got a book all those
things are rectangular I think when
Moses brought the tablets down they were
rectangular we've been kind of working
with the rectangle as a content shape
for a long time so the notion that Apple
should be able to lock that up against
anything that's quite similar for 14
years I think is a sign that maybe we've
stepped over the reasonable boundary
unemployment is still very high is there
anything that we can learn from copying
that can help bring us jobs I guess if I
knew that I'd be on the phone with
Barack Obama but I you know I don't
think so I do think I'll say one thing
on that topic which is just to go back
to fashion so back in 1946 I think
Maurice renter who then was a leading
figure in the New York fashion industry
former head of the fashion originators
guild declared that unless Congress took
action to create a copyright for fashion
designs the industry would lose 600,000
jobs now fast-forward to 2012 and you
hear those same figures bandied around
if we don't do something we're gonna
lose all these jobs in the intervening
decades the industry grew and grew and
became very successful so one lesson I
draw from that is what an industry is
doing well without intellectual property
protection we don't want to introduce
that and that might have detrimental
effects for innovation but also might
have detrimental effects for
unemployment or rather for employment I
don't have a magic bullet for increasing
jobs in the United State
but I don't think increasing jobs for
lawyers which is what a bill like that
would do is the best way to increase
jobs for the economy as a whole you're a
lawyer attacking other lawyers how could
I am but I mean typically when
something's good for lawyers it's
probably not good for everybody else I
think that's a good rule of thumb well
that's a good place to go out on for
reason TV and Paul Dietrich